deux branches monsieur julien aubert la
question s'adresse merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
et les j'associe mon collègue verchères
le temps des cerises touche à sa fin du
moins en france
je ne vous le papa du 49-3 mais d'un
problème beaucoup plus grave depuis le
1er février 2016 vous avez interdit
définitivement le diméthoate en france
un pesticide utilisé dans la culture de
cerises au nom d'impératifs sanitaires
malheureusement en l'absence de
traitement alternatif immédiat la
production française dont une grande
partie est issue du département de
vaucluse risque d'être laminée sous les
attaques des parasites et notamment de
la mouche asiatiques
ma question porte sur l'avenir de la
filière agroalimentaire qui logiquement
s'implante à côté des lieux de
production
votre décision fera indistinctement la
culture de la cerise rouge de table mais
aussi la cerise blanche dit bigarreau
destinés à la transformation
industrielle
les industriels sont extrêmement inquiet
ils pourront importer des cerises
blanche turcs mais traitées au
diméthoate est évidemment plus cher
autant se délocaliser en turquie
aujourd'hui une délégation est reçue à
matignon et bercy pour une réunion de la
dernière chance
les industriels demandent que le produit
puisse être utilisé dans la production
de cerises blanche qui sont destinés à
100% la transformation pour cette
catégorie de cerises contrairement à la
cerise rouge de table qui nécessite
davantage d'interventions le traitement
aux dîmes et aura été prodigués qu'une
seule fois et les trusts prouve qu'il
n'y a plus aucune trace de pesticides
dans le produit temps se transformer
puisqu'il n'ya donc aucun danger pour
les consommateurs de fruits confits et
de cake
il faut traiter différemment les cerises
blanche c'est du bon sens dans le pays
d'apt réputé pour ses fruits confits
l'impact est évalué à un millier
d'emplois directs et indirects et la
perte d'investissement dans l'outil de
fabrication s'élève à plusieurs millions
d'euros
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
pressez les cerises jusqu'à ce que les
pépins on craque
les industriels sont inquiets car ils ne
peuvent lui
d'aucune indemnisation contrairement aux
agriculteurs se seraient considérés
comme des aides d'état illégales au sens
européen en prenant ce monsieur le
premier ministre on cultive le bon sens
vous connaissez l'expression c'est
l'exception qui confirme la règle mais
aussi la parole est à monsieur stéphane
le foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
monsieur le président monsieur le député
dans votre question il ya déjà deux
périodes est une contradiction
vous avez commencé avec la fin de la
production de cerises et vous terminez
avec la cerise blanche spécifiquement
utilisé en industrie vous avez donc
implicitement déjà répondu en partie à
une question l'interdiction du ddt et
beto hat a été fait pour la consommation
de cerises fraîches et je vous rappelle
que c'est pas le ministre qui l'a
interdit l'autorisation de ce produit
c'est lent c'est ce qui n'a pas
renouvelé l'autorisation de mise en
marché
ce que vous me demander monsieur le
député ça s'étripe en moi une dérogation
contraire aux indications de lens est ce
vous croyez que ministre de
l'agriculture
je mettrai sur le marché des cerises qui
pourrait avoir quelques dangers que ce
soit pour les consommateurs c'est non
donc ça c'est le premier point
donc quand vous commencez votre question
avec grandiloquence je vous réponds
deuxième point sur la question des
cerises blanche et de la drosophile
suzuki et du dp toac vous demandez là
aussi une dérogation
je vous indique que le ministère a
proposé des alternatives qu'il en existe
que nous sommes prêts à travailler avec
les industriels et il y aura une réunion
à matignon et à bercy pour discuter avec
eux sur l'utilisation deux cerises qui
peuvent être d'ailleurs tout à fait
utilisable sous forme de saumur ou sous
forme de cerise déjà récolté non fraîche
pour l'utilisation de l'industrie donc
sur ces questions monsieur le député au
lieu de commencer par la fin de la
production des cerises revenons tout
simplement au temps des cerises